طبعا سر
عدم قدره الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
القوات الامريكيه او الاقمار الصناعه لها
تحديد مكان رئيس هو استخدام لاماكن بديله
فاحد هذه الاماكن البديله اللي يضطر اثناء
الحرب يجتمع فيها حكى لي دعاهم في اجتماع
الى في مطعم الساعه
وحال وصول الرئيس حسب ما ذكر لي انتبه الى
عدم وجود شخص لم يذكر اسم الشخص طلب من
عندهم الخروج من الاتجاهين من الجانبين
بعدهم يعني بالقرب من المطعم وانقصف قامت
الطائرات والاصفر هل عرفت من كان ذلك
الشخص لم يحدثني عنه لم يذكر اسم الشخص لم
يذكر لا تصريح ولا تلميح
هل قال لك من يتوقع ان يكون قد كشف موقعه
عند ال الخربيط
[موسيقى]
يعني حمل المسؤوليه لاستخدام الشباب
الموجودين مع الاسر والعوائل لاستخدام
الثريا يعني لا يمكن ان يكون موضوع يعني
خياني وانما استخدام الثريا تحدد من قبل
الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه استخدام
الثريا عاده في يعني معروف عنها امنيا
يعني يستخدم بسياره سيرمالايقل عن 90 كيلو
متر بالساعه ومن ثم يعني بعدها
يخلص يعني او يتحدث يتصل لازم يرميها
ويتركها
فالثريات هي اللي كشفت وجود القوات وجوده
للقوات الامريكيه